[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum king day zu
reportage eisbaden für eine bessere
gesundheit was bringt kälte und zum
übungen ich hoffe im schnitt vor der
reportage nicht dass sie das thema und
das thema muss um so schnieder wenn es
auch eine pass hat oder zu lang ist und
du musst kühler sind die frage der
kommentare und ich gehe sehr gern auf
die burka damit der erste von sandra f
mich würde es interessieren ob du jetzt
weitermacht oder es beide challenge
geblieben ist ich sitze da gott oder
rannte wie sie in zürich dahin eschkotte
zürisee also ich könnte mir noch ein
eisbad ich bin allerdings
nicht da also ich hatte lust zum tag ist
der gott wenn es regnet oder es war
allgemein schlecht ist zudem ich würde
sagen also challenge machen es für mich
als challenger ich kann auch wenn ich
lust habe
ja erst zweimal in der woche wiesbaden
es tut mir extrem gut accent freund hat
mich auch das lied tatsächlich motiviert
hat zum auffangen oder das mal wäre zum
beispiel schriftzug erfolg zum kalte
dusche jetzt
schaue ich jetzt nicht für mich ich das
nicht gerne enthält die so
unkontrolliert vordergrund ich mache so
ab und zu nach dem sport turnier gerne
eine kalte dusche für mich ist vergangen
aber wenn du es schaffst dann könnt ihr
ein weiterer spannender kommentare china
kommt von jungs nur warum man hier mit
dem kopf ist wasser russische forscher
das minus 2 grad ist und ja gut wenn es
findet nicht sehr abnehme ist und man
verliert hat afrika und tut man sich
gerne an das andere argument ist das
halt wenn du aber doch und wenn du
kannst du früher eigentlich schon genug
also gut wenn du sechs minuten trinkt
sie bis acht minuten bewegung im wasser
im gebüsch und unser kunst du du wirst
du bestraft beschäftigt mit acht im
körper aufzuwärmen und wenn dann nur
nach sicherheitsgefühl acht das ist too
much dann sind das bak kommentare mit
medizinische frage und theologisch jetzt
immer wieder konnten bergsteiger
zu halten
ich möchte zum ersten kommentar
vom lpv geschrieben hat man sollte das
eisbaden auch eins bis drei mal die
woche beschränken auch hier macht die
dosis das gift kalt duschen kann man
jeden tag wie auch die atemübung
willst du sagen dass dem dass man kein
film ist oder das kann irgendwann
kontraproduktiv sie
xy ein symbol und effekte wenn es da
geht noch was reißen aber aber schädlich
ist sicher nur zahlen pro stelle naja
also kann man zu stressig die es ist
sich für technologie mit dem sport tv
was du warst du selbst kriegt ist es
sinnvoll jede des trainings machen die
massiven intensität dieses sinnvoll die
die die regenerativen pause direkt
sicher aber ich war kurz und london ist
halt so wurde die kalte dusche
aber klar ist dass tv
aber gerne etwa
jede dritte und sektor ist mehr möglich
für mich wieder breitensport sehen
aber es klingt etwas machen mit mit
weiteren motivation erinnern und im
marathon caritas muss
qualität einer open für herzkreislauf
bestätigen nicht dass nicht nur aber
kann man sage fit für die kälte effekt
habe ich es auch nicht nötig jeden tag
egal was kritiker mit der nächsten frage
vom markt ein vorher nachher vergleich
der weißen blutkörperchen wäre auch
interessant gewesen bei vielen steigen
sie nämlich merklich an
ja selbst die neue kraft bisher den
versuch als wissenschaftliche know
ventile klein du weißt überspannt aber
in der theorie durch den effekt hat mir
mehr wie sie blut körper tauschen der
stiege zu teuer und die sind wichtig für
war es um kaspar das ist intakt april
also das klassische männer für
interaktionen nicht dass es den verlagen
snow crash sage dass er in der korona
alt da wird nur fiel wie sieben köpfen
hätte ich wahrscheinlich automatisieren
und der polo ganz wenig hat
da kommen die interaktions laufen oder
anschlussproblemen
mio brl allerdings total neu
definiert sind und wenn wir durchgesetzt
das kalte wasser
wie sie block abartig werden besser
geschützt gegen so ein fakt allgemein
das letzte was die theoretisch
geschichten und kündigte forsch eine
eigene schule bis hin zu haben und ich
dass das funktioniert also effektiv zum
teil bereits auf könne man so den
anschluss verpassen können jetzt messen
müssten natürlich über längere phasen in
einer krankheitsdauer und krankheit in
der chance heute möchte ich zum nächsten
kommentare das ist der logical m
polizist schreibt geht auch kalt duschen
oder gibt es da einen fundamentalen
unterschied zwischen einem fahrrad und
der dusche also gut die frage sind zwar
respekt eindeutig durch holzfasern oder
einfach süß
wassereffekten eines dynamischen und
ausländern sehr
kalt duschen
positiven fakten 57 christen werden am
zaun ist natürlich im schwimmerischen
fracht und im see oder im fluss die noch
denn du bist mein gesamter mut und
verstand der parcours zum teil wieder
geschmückt das heißt position mitten
drin und das ich für chelsea
spielte das keine rolle kinderglück für
chrysler spekulation ist das ganz
wichtig sei es empfohlen wird ja nicht
wenn wir damit der kreislauf nicht ganz
genau oder damit man sich bewusst wird
genau
und weiß noch was was was mit erfahrung
noch aussage metallischer dauern
unterschied ob man die kalte dusche bad
oder gott ist es was also ich verstehe
die individuell vierte anders aber ich
finde kalte dusche schlimmer als wasser
so
vordergrund und sozusagen spritzt und im
ins wasser wenn ich in der natur und ich
glaube mich auf das erlebnis ist kalte
wasser und es ist viel einfacher zum
entspannen also traut dusche zum
trainer-job alte und so mache ist viel
schwieriger als ist einfach so schön
entspannt rita und ort weder
kontrollieren ich glaube das ist
etwas was macht mir spaß mit
neuen kommentarische nico von andreas
wittwer
schwimmen gehen will braucht unbedingt
ein gesundes herz denn mehr probleme mit
dem herz kreislauf hat sollte aufs
schwimmen verzichten
pikant der kälteschock nämlich zu
rhythmusstörungen oder sogar zum
herzstillstand führen lassen wer schon
als recht hat also falls ein herzinfarkt
oder
rhythmusstörung der hat das wird diese
erste ärzte-teams
sich kreislaufbelastung
und das herz kreislauf schlagen nicht an
konzerte und dieselbe wer
herz-kreislauf-problemen hat wenn man
nur dort zum beispiel
mit mit dem berg ruby
couchepin nicht dann ist das offizielle
europa wo das jetzt nicht weiß ob ein
herzfehler hat aachen herzstillstand
bekommen kalte wasser
theorie ist wahrscheinlich wirklich
große
sache werden
und
wirken so
und medikamente nimmt das problem
ich lustig in öko vom kind könnte man
eisbaden mit heilfasten ohne gefahr
kombinieren
[Musik]
verschiedene raumes kombinieren aber er
übt das sinnvoll ist
das nicht dann wirklich ein stressiges
frau gezahlt ich würde man so sagen
entweder sie gewöhnlich 33 unterstützt
jetzt auch das gut kennt und oder wo
sich als haupt und handtaschen
aufenthalt mündlich
habe aber als als beginn aber die
meinten unternehmer und würdigsten mache
er verglich
lustige frage will ich habe immer so
fest
und ich hatte das immer so so als als
königssee nachdem wiesbaden noch eine
große branche
leiste oder durch den stress nicht und
dann ist die eigentlich die erste
antwort sinnvoll gewesen der körper
macht also ich jetzt keinen kommentar
viele fragen sind spezifisch
inspektor dass das irgendwie
ausspricht oder mehr beschäftigt als der
ewige jopi ich gemerkt hat wie wir sind
für mich recht wichtig sie mental und
außer der energie muss halt irgendwie
habe ich mich fit gefühlt nach nach
denen hat mehr bringen und nichts macht
und ich mache ja weiterhin jetzt nur es
ist einfach zu dem china co von patrick
stehen niemand was ist der unterschied
wenn man die atemübung weglässt oder
besser gefragt kann man sie überhaupt
weglassen also kam es bei der ideale weg
machen
kann die grandiosen taufrischen kodex ka
news aus dem rettungskorb text natürlich
liegt das trainiert wird hier rein
physikalisch und und krönen können die
chancen rechnet sich auch und wieder
rein ohne in den alten heerweg zu machen
ich stelle mir vor dass ich
körperlich und mental auf draußen wir
jetzt am schluss die vormittags wird
wenn ihr tatsächlich wirklich vielfältig
sie oder mainz ist celtic siviglia oder
test macht das ist
aber ich bin einfach so
21 kommuniziere jetzt damit
also das vorstellen sagt thomas sich für
mich ich danken will und das mit michael
du bist du also eineinhalb jahre idee
das sieht übrigens
ohne die ihnen sonst dass du da
irgendwie immer zwei drei tagen verfällt
im fliesen etc ist sinnlos
danke für das gespräch
danke für mal natürlich auch für die
viele spannende frage wo in korinth ich
hoffe dass man so ein oder anderen hand
könne beantwortete natürlich auch
weiterhin kommentiert der uni der
kommentarspalte ich würde mir das
allergie und vergaß nicht die kanal zu
abonnieren